they drove us album what i assume must
be the northeastern pyongyang
to a very slummy area where
well
to be honest not the
kind of north korea they want to show
people
but in my opinion it is a real north
korea then and they asked us to go down
in a basement in one of these
old houses which were about to collapse
i was like waiting for the the sound of
a gun having to know
loading it and then lights out
[Music]
i grew up in the southern part of
denmark in a town called naxco
it's located 170 kilometers south of
copenhagen
and my dad he works on the ferry who
sails to germany and that was before it
was reunited as the germany we know
today so sometime he went to the west
another time to the east but one day i
went with my dad on the boat to east
germany
and i was told by the staff on the boat
when we arrived don't go down there
because
you will probably be shot or kidnapped
or tortured orders what's it even worse
because they are communist and you know
telling that to a child my age at that
time 10
11 years of age was quite scary so
i stayed of course on board on the ferry
but during one of those trips i met up
with an east german
boy named mike
and then we exchanged addresses and
became pen pals and at one point my
family said well let's go to east
germany and meet up with this kid's
family
and you know coming from the place i was
born and raised to east germany during
the cold war was like a big shock for me
they were nothing in the shops and we
waited two and a half hour at the bakery
for a piece of bread
it was just
completely
out of my world
but you know i paid a lot of attention
to it and
then i grew up and you know time changes
the wall went down the two germans were
reunited and i had an education as a
chef
and
after 10 years of working as a chef i
had an incurable disease in my pancreas
which prevented me working as a chef and
made me a lot spent a lot of time in the
hospital
i found it interesting enough to reach
out to mas boiger and never expected
master reach back but
but he did and well so to speak the rest
is now history to be honest my idea was
not even close to what we ended out to
be i had this naive thought that i could
film those
people
walking around north korea in
well
like monty python and north korea kind
of style because they are funny people
with funny statesmen and i'm a big fan
of mountain biking and i saw some
similarities with those people um
the chairman could easily be john cleese
or something
but you know that was actually my whole
idea but
and the thing was how can i
actually going to film these people and
now we are back in 2011 and i
went to a meeting telling them hey
you know this media called youtube and
the member of the association is all
plus 60 years so they was just looking
at each other like no what is it
so i explained what youtube is and that
i could film some
small propaganda videos telling the real
story about north korea
and the chairman he loved to see himself
on the big screen and he was like
let's do it
after five or six days in north korea i
was awarded with a friendship medal of
the regime and i had the badges from the
leaders which
shows to me that they respect me and i
respect which is very important is to
respect the leaders of the country
and when i had those batches and mellows
it was like all doors opened for me
this is a jacket from my north korean
soup which i had taylor made back in
2017 in pyongyang
this is the batches of the leader which
shows the leaders who was dead now and
kim wilson and kim jong-il
you only give to people who the regime
trust
and wearing this around in pyongyang on
north korea it just shows a population
that you are accepted you are
you are friendly to the country you you
will practically die for the nation to
to defend him about the evil capitalism
at one point i met alejandro cao de
venis he ended up telling me that if i
could find somebody who wants to invest
money in north korea and at that point
he's talked about 50 000 euros to a
million euros
we could maybe do something so literally
he wanted me to find an investor so for
three years i walked around in all
meetings in europe and kfa
you know
hosting a speech or
you know
just loving north korea and all the
i think i went to probably six or seven
countries for three years
participating in
in meetings from
who was arranged by the kfa
and alejandro gets more and more pushy
to me like have you found an investor
and i was like
you know if i came up with one the first
day it would look quite suspicious
so to speak the day before we didn't
have an investor and i have a reinsta
meeting in oslo with alejandro and an
investor
and
we just came up with
mr james which is uh
his real name is jim and jim is a former
criminal in denmark he spent eight years
in prison for selling cocaines to the
to the jet set people in copenhagen he
knew the criminal game he wasn't just
then you know
a random person it was actually a person
who knew about drugs and and weapons
from his past so
and now he was representing this
rich family and i think it was norway we
told him he was
they were located um so we just went to
oslo me and mr james met up in the
airport had a breakfast
spent 20 minutes to find out a cover
story which we never used
and
luckily enough alejandro he was he was
in love with mr james or at least a deep
pocket of mr james for for the regime
and just being there for five minutes
with
alejandro and mr james alejandro he just
said
what he could present from north korea
what mr team was able to buy and
we were like when the meeting was always
like if if this is true it's
well
we just
got something that north korea is doing
sanctioning busting or at least trying
to
but also kept in mind that maybe
alejandro just trying to
to fool us and just to reach out the
money of mr james
well what happened thing next is that
i'm actually
was taught by we had a security man
behind the
the mall
and he decided that if this need to go
further on i need some training somehow
how to act as an undercover agent
and so i went to the u.s and spent a
little week with a former ca agent in
field training with how to do and what
not to do
and actually on the flight home to
copenhagen from washington
i got aware that alejandro was arrested
in spain for arms trafficking so
it was not just some story alejandro
came up with
and from then on the north sorry the
spanish government withdrawn alejandro's
passport
and he was not able to leave spain
and that put me in a whole new position
because
alejandro has been working on bringing
me and mr james to north korea to meet
up with the right people as he says
and
and suddenly i was
i was alejandro i was a man with with
the power from kfa to bring in mr james
to north korea
well arriving in north korea
with mr james i i was just walking out
of the flight and down to the border
patrol and there was this officer opened
my bag and saw my camera
and he was like
i need to speak with my a higher ranking
officer and i was like oh [ __ ]
um but then mr kang which were my
contact person in in north korea
he was like hey all right don't you have
your badges and medals with you yeah of
course and so i have a badger in the
middle from the regime and i just
literally opened my jacket and showed to
that officer and he was like
i'm so sorry and really put all the
things down my back and closed it and
gave it to me and bowing for me he was
very sorry that he
interrupted me and
like he did something wrong i was like
oh it's his job so don't be sad but he
was like wow this foreign person is
really some somebody here in north korea
so i literally walked through with my
cameras and everything out in a waiting
mercedes-benz and drove to the hotel
we spent two days actually just walking
around talking and they were showing a
lot of
things which was nothing that alejandro
promised us we would talk with the north
koreans about
so i took mr kang aside and said hey
in 96 hours
i would be in a flight with mr james
back to denmark and we haven't been
shown anything of what alejandro told mr
james
so you're probably losing a investor
here if you you don't
speed it up
and well next morning
we were asked to be ready
a bit faster than normal
and we went down in our car and they
drove us out in what i assume must be
the northeastern pyongyang
to a very slummy area where
well
to be honest down the road we're running
faces and urine from from the house
blocks it was
it was not the
kind of north korea they wanted to show
people
but in my opinion it is a real north
korea then
and they asked us to go down in a
basement in one of these
old houses which were about to collapse
and i was literally expecting
that my time on earth when ran out
because
i was like waiting for the the sound of
a gun having to know
loading it and then
lights out but
the door was like
this thick and was covered in black
leather and it was really scary but
start opening it it was some like
fire works or something lights inside
and i was really you know trying to keep
calm and
i could see a gym that okay this is
probably not a good way
to end up our lives here but because
nobody wants to hear from us again or
found out what happened to our bodies
but then we walked in this room with a
karaoke machine running and a
big round table with i think they will
could could be eight seed or something
and a lot of food and beers and sodas
and wine everything
and then we were told that the president
from the uh
state-owned
weapons factory in arraya trading will
attend in the meeting and so would the
president of the medical industry as
well
and
they just showed up in this room and
thinking back now they want us to go
down there because it was a place where
they felt secure and nobody would hear
what jude was talking about and no but
nothing could you know nothing came in
or out
and
sitting there they just took out like a
pizza menu a card with all the weapon
systems on how to use them
the prices the quantity and the time to
deliver and you know
practically the whole weapon system in
north korea besides the nuclear weapon
systems
they went we have even tamarbaric
missiles on the menu for
that they would like to sell to mr james
so we were literally
you know surprised down there and still
expecting us not to leave that room
and live
but then suddenly
the president of the arms factory he
stood up grabbing out for a microphone
and then he started singing karaoke just
in the middle of an interpretation and i
was like what the hell is happening here
and then they want me to sing
and
i'm a bad singer
and no doubt about it and
but the north korean culture is like
like like it says in south korea that if
you ask to sing a song it's very
unpolite just don't want to do it
but the i don't know if they thought i
looked like her but they put on celine
dion my heart will go on from titanic so
i literally sang two two lines and asked
him to stop the music and say hey
i'm spoiling a very very beautiful song
so what i did not to lose my face was
actually i started to sing a children's
song which i was saying for my children
while they were very small and doing
some of the
um the funny things you do among the
song and
and that made the north koreans so happy
and they hugged me and kissed me because
as they said we could feel it comes from
your heart
this comes from your heart which means
you love your children
and our leader and that's the most
important thing in north korea always
love the leader otherwise you're screwed
so you talked about this weapon deal
what are were the other things that
throughout this 10 years you've exposed
in um north korea with north korean
government with the deal was they making
and stuff
well what scares me the most is that
north korean is operating in africa
when we had the meeting in pyongyang
we agreed on because i said hey
i'm very happy being in north korea i
love it i have to play my role i love i
love the leader i love the country i
will do anything for north korea but
it would be quite suspicious if me and
mr james will travel in and out of north
korea 10 20 times a year
to to just talk with you guys here
because that would make some attention
for some intelligent service if those
two danish people were traveling in and
out
so
the north korean came up with the idea
that we could
find a place in africa
to build up a factory to produce our own
weapons and mr james could you know
literally sell them from there then
north koreans will send
you know the workers to africa they will
build the factory and they've literally
shown us papers of how it should be and
they had cooperation with namibia at
that point so we decided to go to
namibia
but the in the period of time before
entering there in namibia caught the
connection to north korea so then next
country was it was uganda
and we figured out it could be very
right to buy an island in the lake
victoria
in the
ugandan part of the lake so we could
do our things
peacefully and ride the government to
yeah just to be there and look the other
way
we then went to uganda
first to meet up with some real estate
broker about buying an island and many
people has been asking
how do you find an island for sale in
in the lake victoria out of uganda and
coastline and it was like well it's
quite easy you just googled it we said
adam for sale uganda victoria lake and
came up with an offer so we've we get in
contact with those real estate brokers
and
we went out to see the island and it was
a cost of five million dollars which was
in mr james quite cheap so we took a two
hours boat ride from kampala to the
island
and
when we get close to the island we could
see a lot of people
in a little harbor and they were dancing
and screaming and it looked like they
had fun
we've got a very warm welcome me and mr
james and were quite surprised because
we were actually trying to buy this
island but just before entering the
island the real estate broker told us
hey
don't tell them you want to buy this
island because i told them
that you guys are here because you want
to build a medical clinic to care for
the people here
at that point i really wanted to beat up
that real estate burger with something
cheap and hard because i think it's so
cruel too
well those people would never have
another place to go
what happened next is that
the north koreans
also came to uganda
and
the problem is north koreans
traveling around the world are not
traveling on north korean passports
because
being in kampala during a lunch
i talked with one of the
people from one of the
business men from north korea
that
you know chit-chatting and i was like
hey how is think back in pyongyang how
was mr kang kang was not attending and
he literally jumped across the table
holding for my mouth hey
shut up
we're not north korean we're chinese
we're traveling on chinese passport and
he weighed a chinese passport for me
which makes big concerns for me because
if china
gives passports to north korean
criminals to travel around the world to
do business
we have a big problem
because already now china is deep into
the market in africa and if the north
korean goes in to do production of
weapons of medium vitamin and africa it
could look really bad for yeah
especially for world peace we brought to
north koreans to copenhagen to sign a
final contract of the whole
no cooperation with we have to produce
weapons in africa we would buy oil in
jordan who will send the oil to north
korea and and that will make the payment
for mr james to produce the weapons that
he couldn't sell and buy so it was like
a triangle deal
and if all those things happened well
what could we have done we could have
been selling weapons to isis or
yeah as i said before syria or
just terrorist organization or even
start a civil war in a minor country if
you wanted to
so was that when you blew your cover and
you
gave that information further on how how
how did you put the end of the to the
operation
well we have arranged at the hotel
danglite which is the most
beautiful hotel in copenhagen in whole
denmark the most exclusive place
and we have arranged the north koreans
to meet up with mr james in a suite
and there we would sign the final
agreements and put an order of weapons
and
in that meeting
mr james was really you know
looking forward to he was really happy
like and let them know that
this is gonna be the most fantastic
thing for north korea for many years and
we i could literally see by knowing
spending so much time with north koreans
in north korea and outside north korea
that mr jew as your name was he was
being filled up with proudness of
coming back with those papers and
signing and it was
it was
some
some kind of you know touching in some
in other ways it's like okay now
now it's
soon will be over
and after the signing our next step was
literally to pay up front five but
around eight million us dollar upfront
to to make the next process going on and
of course
we wouldn't even pay 50 cents because
otherwise we would have been breaking
all the laws against north korean
sanction
so what happened was that um
mr james he disappeared i spent
a whole year
trying to figure out what happened to mr
james which i knew that was happened but
i was you know really playing
a role play with with great acting
skills and then
kovit came and
it was like okay what what should we do
now what is the next step and i was
still had the contact
and at one point in september
in 2020
we agreed on now it's time to tell the
truth to alejandro
so we when i told and i did ask
alejandro he wanted to be a part of
a storytelling about north korea because
i was going to a school to tell the kids
about
north korea and
some of the kids found out this there's
this fantastic mr alejandro cowderpin as
the president of kfa and they would
really much if he could be on a soon
connection to answer some questions
and
alejandro he likes to be seen and heard
and he was like oh i'm ready to this i'm
ready
we show then went to a hotel and i was
having a chit chat with him before say
hey
i'll be ready in 10 minutes a student
has to go in in their seats and then
i will go online with you just to tell
you a few things on how many questions
and blah blah blah
and
what i first got aware of very late in
this project was that back in 2006 when
mass boycott did research for the red
chapel
he went to north korea
and he used alejando as he's a man to
bring him into north korea and because
of the red chapel alejandro hates
masboyga
and certainly now i will be sitting next
to the man that alejandro
hates the most maybe and now the one he
trusts the most me will be
he has been working with this guy for 10
years next to me so i was really scared
of
when i was telling my story for him that
he will literally hang up because
it was so important for me to have mass
sitting next to me so alejandro could
see us together
and i think it's it took me 20 seconds
to tell alejandro that i've been the
mole for 10 years
then that everything is just uh yeah
it's a documentary
and that he has to meet this person and
i think looking back now alejandro
thought i was like prank doing a prank
on him or something because he literally
trusted me so much that i met his
parents and family
and
a mass just say hey alejandro we meet
again
nice to see you
this is being recorded and
all the things
in the past with ulrich has been
recording
and we can just just lift up his arm
how did your family react when you
opened up to them
when i have to and after
when i told my wife it was you know the
day before i told her hey
tomorrow there will come some people
who are
they are doing a documentary and i've
been helping a bit with the cameras
which was my cover story for her that i
went into a movie company and helped
them with their equipment and that was
what made me able to travel around the
world without chiefs paying any notice
to what i was doing and didn't ask me
any questions
then the
mask came the
photographer came the producer came and
we had a cup of coffee and
and then we started shooting it and
and matt said hey i think alright got
something he wants to tell you
so
i told her my story and i think it was
two or three hours just talking with her
and
and
but and she but as he said
i don't understand this but are we in
danger what is going to happen now have
you been in danger i was like well
yeah i've been but i'm here today and
well
you just wait to see the
documentary so you it will maybe give
you an idea
are you
ever scared or like paranoid about
anything about the fact that north korea
officials can get to you somehow or
anything like that
well i use some of the skills that i was
taught by the
cia agent in washington
um but i i think i'm that kind of person
who
who
doesn't go out in public like trying to
to to
get attention from people
but i think now that the world has
opened more after the pandemic
there are places which i would be more
aware of if going there
and i've also been told there is a lot
of countries with the intelligence
has asked me kindly not to even consider
visiting again like of course north
korea but
i don't
they don't want me to go to china to
uganda
jordan
syria russia belarus those kind of
countries
are you glad about what you achieved
with that alejandro is as you said as
now wanted man you've exposed the weapon
deals and stuff like that do you feel
sense of achievement from all of that
well i think with alejandro we have only
seen the top of the iceberg
but you know thinking back now
i think that the fbi has been into all
this and maybe other authorities as well
and that is the reason why
he wasn't arrested when the mall was
released because they were really
getting evidence against him to to
remove him
and now he's among the most wanted and
on the run i guess
so
and even that if he goes on the run it
just shows me that he is a he is a
criminal and
he went out on twitter asking for
lawyers to help him so i think he is
really
he's really fearing what's going to
happen now i think he could face up to
20 years in prison and i find which
could be easily a million
british pounders
and out of everything you've been
through
is there anything you regret
um
no not really because
i have at any time i had the chance just
to say
stop
it this is it
and but i think that the timing between
the the things that happened i had the
time to digest what i've just been
through
maybe i regret not to be honest to my
wife and family of course because those
are the people i loved
loved the most
but once again i think the love for me
was also to protect them
and they arrest me in front my five
years old child
my heart is just beat with
and i know that is if i arrested and
sent back to north korea
i just execute or prison camp